[Music]
this is a um this is a nice turn of
events a former porn star
who made quote well over a million
dollars
is now a pastor wow nice we've we've
followed a story like that before right
yeah there's so many i think people that
go from
um
porn to childhood porn
to child oh god or like this guy right
here okay you know what i mean soldier
for god now dude because we did another
one where it was a couple
they were porn star couple oh wow yeah
we should look up story articles the
other way right like like pastors that
turn into porn stars oh that's a good
one it's like more useful right yeah
well okay what happened there
we need more of those dudes yeah we need
that in our life yeah so a man who's
made well over a million dollars work in
the porn industry now works as a pastor
his name is joshua broome and he's
filmed more than 1 000 x-rated movies
under his old stage name
rocco reed oh that's rocco no way good
for him
quick familiarity right now it's stupid
he had a really good selection i believe
him great thing
got a great dick on it
i believe him it's if it's a denzel
movie
exactly you're the guy for that you
really know rocco reed
oh no
rocco i know rocco i don't know i don't
know
rocco it might be the same guy named
rocco i've been to that pizza place a
couple times
it's so crazy how how much more money
male porn stars make without even being
like super known well dude if you made
if you made a million dollars he's a
thousand films that's not the wraith's
not great he's probably it's probably
he's making that that's a thousand
dollars [ __ ]
he's making that much either uh if he
produced it that's different too oh yeah
because uh actually uh male porn stars
make less and that's why a lot of them
do um
gay to gay porn because that pays more
for the for the actors it's like 10x
more apparently yeah for a call or
something called gay gay for pagan gay
oh no i didn't think it was that
i'm like joe knows all the info on this
one
it doesn't roll off the top like that
for tater tots it's a it's a program
you guys aren't enrolled
that's a nick done original do you know
that they get paid way more for gay porn
yeah they get yeah yeah yeah me and bart
was searching it for some reason i think
we're like
i'm like joe really knows his stuff on
this we're trying to find like some kind
of um we're doing research for like some
porn we're trying to get hired
yeah we're trying to find some passive
income that's not passive yeah
i was like what can i still do that i
will enjoy maybe some porn and then i
was like oh guy porn stars make nothing
was there an article beat was it like
can you wear a luchador mask while you
do gay porn
[Laughter]
other guys are already asking that
question
it's just auto filled man 300 bucks okay
if i look like rey mysterio who cares
everyone looks like right with steroids
it is so funny though when you watch all
these like um because like on pornhub
it's like youtube you can build your own
channels and [ __ ] like that right so the
girl would be like completely
shown and then the dude would be all
covered up and i'm like why are you so
bashful no one's looking at you
why is that why it happens but i also
think it's because guys that are
watching
want to pretend that they're the ones
[ __ ] her and it ruins it when they
see a man's face
yeah because i always want to be like
that's my huge black dick
so this guy was in the port industry for
about six years quit in 2012 because he
said it caused him a tremendous amount
of emotional trauma
oh you gotta [ __ ] all the chicks all the
time
snooze he's like oh no she's sucking out
another night
so much emotional pain for getting my
dick sucked and having sex with all
these options
becoming a pastor he did state i would
like to state that my time in the adult
industry in every aspect has now come to
an end and i would also like to state
that i am not nor have ever been gay
just an adult performer okay he sounds
insecure
he's like yeah we even ask you about
that i have not ever been gay
well is it because he did gave her pay
well yeah he did gave her pay that's why
see so he's just calling himself an
adult performer but then also i'm i'm
guessing especially becoming a pastor uh
after doing gay like porn one thing
right guitars of the flesh but gave her
pain the [ __ ] out of a dick on video but
i'm not gay
yeah
i'm not do you think that's unbelievable
are the awards over like hey dude you
seem pretty gay that was good and he's
like thank you because i was acting
like you
best blow job of the year just a gold
dick i know look at this wow
i don't deserve this i'm straight but
yeah i guess you know best blow job
that's if he drives here enough he gets
choked up
do you think there's like a petition
from
you know the gay community like hey we
need to have real representation in the
porn industry these [ __ ] straight
guys taking our roles pretending to be
gay [ __ ] that [ __ ] we need real gay men
they're appropriating yeah i speak on it
bro that issue does not uh it doesn't
get enough press never been talking
about once yeah they need real actors
that are representative of the community
i agree what's up with all this [ __ ]
mm-hmm
well people can you know it's it's not
necessarily gay anymore if you're just
like you know pan-sexual in that sense
right what does pansexual mean
i don't know does that mean that you can
uh you pretty much
are sexually attracted to everything
everybody no i think it has to do with
dishware
now i'm going to look it up
no there's a term not limited in sexual
choice with regard to biological sex
gender or gender identity
what's
there's an actual term for it it's
called uh men that have sex with men
but they're straight oh yeah
men
who have sex with men but aren't gay
yeah sex i remember at the old gym i
used to work at the front desk girl was
reading a book about msm
and it was like from the library and i
was like asking questions about it
because it was pretty interesting like
you don't really see people reading
books about men who have sex with men
who don't claim themselves to be gay but
it's like a very popular thing
so terms are
multi-dimensional
sexual fluidity
uh
closeted gaze
i don't get it
i'm not really seeing a parallel yeah i
don't know if i'm gonna finish reading
this but what about guys who just want
to [ __ ] for fun it's like hey let's just
have you know we have a couple hours
this is fun these are triple f's triple
f [ __ ] more fun
do you think
that might happen at like the gym though
from time to time it's like dudes that
are just working out that like really
looked very very very sexy and
attractive or just like man i've been
working on my body for like a decade and
i could tell you putting work in yours
like i want to examine
your your body yeah i bet that happens
is this how andrew's starting to write
fanfic
the first page
dude you've been working out right you
know it's like one of those yeah yeah
yeah that's the first line too hey
you've been working out he cracked his
smile
and he goes thank you for noticing we
should have sex now that's how it goes
hey can you spot me
he spotted me i'm looking up at his nuts
right yeah yeah dude when nick wants to
[ __ ] he just grabs his wife and picks
her up and [ __ ] lost her in the other
room i wish i was that manly dude i wish
i'm worried about will smith type of
vibe yeah
[Laughter]
everything's open and she has sex with
everybody else but me like honey can you
tie me up first
that's the little smith
carry me he's the will smith kind of guy
we have an open relationship where i
just watch my wife [ __ ] people i don't
[ __ ] anybody else but she box everywhere
dude what if the word cuck goes away and
we just say oh dude this guy's a real
real he's a real will smith i think he's
close dude yeah i think he's one more
slap away from everyone saying like
everyone hating him
thank god
he wants to have sex with everybody that
guy everybody
but isn't there a rumor about will smith
being gay
yeah there's a rumor that was like an
open relationship where they're also
pansexual yeah oh is it or is it
polyamorous i don't know
there was a one of my clients told me
there was a will smith quote about how
he was having sex so much that every
time he would orgasm he would vomit yeah
he talks about that in his book
really yeah and how long ago how would
you vomit from [ __ ] so much that's
your arch nemesis dude in the last video
we did
because i
fall asleep before i couldn't even vomit
is that a clue are we getting a clue you
first have to have that much [ __ ]
available okay that's true because if if
he's having sex so much that he's
throwing up i can only think about one
orgasm don't worry like when he comes
throwing up all the semen yeah yeah yeah
he goes through or he's getting like his
[ __ ] mouth [ __ ]
his fingers in his throat
yes i believe i believe will smith is
polyamorous in practice of or desire for
intimate relationships with more than
one partner with the informed consent of
all partners involved so i believe
doesn't mean gay it just means you just
means he's a cuck
just means he likes
flesh do you think he was crushing it
more than jake lover he for sure was he
he had to be right he had to be what
yeah you're crushing him more than jada
yeah he's a lot probably yeah i bet
those numbers are lopsided yeah i mean
he was the fresh prince like that was a
huge like you can't not get [ __ ] with
stephen hillary bro
carlton was getting so much [ __ ] wow
he still is fresh prince
uncle phil was johnny dude yeah uncle
phil was gay
uncle oh was he i think he was gay rpm
yeah i think so yeah yeah you're right
well he's a great job playing a straight
man no you're right and i don't mind
that you know he did a great job i don't
mind i don't mind that as a stranger
that's appropriation uncle phil and carl
winslow or gay carl winslow's game wait
carl wins this guy i didn't know that no
original development
oh he's the cop right yeah yeah the
die-hard cop yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
reginald bell johnson
who played carl's winslow and family
match was rumored to be gay and in a
relationship with james avery who played
uncle phil wow
wait oh that's a dope ass couple oh
[ __ ] power couple that's a thai
couple man and carl winslow
that's that's a dope couple that's a
dope it really is dawg
and that's good acting yeah they're both
great actors very good acting i always
had rumors like that about eddie murphy
too
eddie murphy oh yeah i heard that i
heard that but every dude i swear to god
in hollywood there's rumors about them
after that like dr dre
yeah that's why uh tupac and dr dre had
a fallen out and then when he made um
there's two songs actually with uh i
think it was california love but they he
had the version without dr dre and at
the end of the song he said without gay
ass dre
and then and you know everyone just
called each other gay back then but then
he really was um he had suspicion of dre
um
either like um taking advantage of one
of his interns male interns or like
basically uh
sexually harassing the men in his record
company and then tupac wasn't cool with
that
and then i think he tried to come on
as well yeah so then
so then they had a falling out and
that's one of the that's one of the i
guess like old school west coast hip-hop
rumors right and he even even said the
same thing about dr dre so i guess a lot
of people were who had fallen out with
dre was was you know dude imagine dr dre
cat calling everybody at death row
records tell the assistant well no this
has been for a long time cause i heard
him and method man used to used to blow
each other
excuse me guys i'm trying to actually
tell a story hip-hop history yo
history so yeah i heard that that dr dre
and method man used to blow each other
but then but dre wouldn't actually suck
method man's dick
he would like he would let method man
blow him but he wouldn't suck his head
when it was his turn and they had a
falling out and it met method man was
like yo what's up bro what's up
oh you know i gotta go i gotta i gotta
just do [ __ ] beats by dre and [ __ ]
you know and so then redman had to suck
method man's dick
and that's how they started hooking up
and that's how they made it
that way is that way dre says nothing
comes out when i use my lips
bunch of gibberish cause he's got a dick
in his mouth
just a bunch of gibberish
i didn't realize that that was dick
it's like why is he saying gibberish oh
there's a dick in my mouth
nice got it i did i did pull up right
now um tupac's 96 album the don kuhlman
seven day theory there were some liner
notes that he had written so one of them
was up for auction and then in this page
this is michael villali machiavelli
illuminati the seven blah blah and it
says a bunch of lines and it says to dr
dre for being a closet homo
maybe that's just like some good
old-fashioned ribbon
some 90s ribbon yeah
but yeah could it be yeah clearly
gibberish
cisco's gay
no really
what are you talking about though
he's talking about g-string
that last line
is good
[Music]
hmm